- [Announcer] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- I'd like to thank Tim and Pat
for inviting me to this
very interesting symposium,
and of course, the entire
CARTA organization.
Language coevolved with the human brain
throughout evolution of Homo sapiens.
Writing, on the other hand,
which is actually what my topic is,
is a relatively new technology
that was invented by humans
to translate spoken
language into a visual form
for the purpose of transmitting
verbal communication
broadly, to many people, over
large distances and time.
As such, reading and writing can be
considered the first social media.
Reading is an example of what's
called neuronal recycling,
the recruitment of previously
evolved neural circuits
to accomplish cultural innovations.
It's important to point out that
while language develops
naturally in most humans,
based on exposure rather
than explicit instruction,
reading and writing require
painstaking instruction
and years of practice
to reach proficiency.
This slide shows the typical reading
brain network with its key components,
as established initially in an older view
by studies of patients with
acquired brain lesions.
And more recently, using modern
brain imaging technologies,
we have a lot more information.
This talk will trace the history
of the invention of writing,
how English writing developed and ended up
with such a cockeyed spelling system,
which leads in many cases to dyslexia,
and discuss how modern technologies
are impacting reading and writing today.
I'd like to begin with a brief overview
of the history of the
invention of writing.
Writing is the physical
manifestation of a spoken language.
It's thought that human beings
developed spoken language
about 35,000 BC, as evidenced by,
(audible dissent from audience)
wow, yeah, by cave paintings
from the period of Cro-Magnon man.
Writing numbers for the
purpose of record-keeping
began long before writing of language.
Written language doesn't
emerge until the invention
in Sumer in Southern
Mesopotamia around 3500 BC.
This writing system is
known as cuneiform writing.
It's generally agreed that
true writing of language
was independently conceived and developed
by at least two ancient
civilizations, and possibly more.
In Sumer, and also in Mesoamerica
by the Maya in 500 to 300 BC.
Writing systems also arose
in Egypt around 3100 BC
and China around 1200 BC.
But historians debate
whether these writing systems
were developed completely
independently of Sumerian writing,
or whether either or both were inspired
by Sumerian writing by a
process of cultural diffusion.
The Sumerian cuneiform writing system
was in use for more than three millennia,
through several stages of development
as can be seen on this slide
by looking at the transformation
of the sign for head, SAG,
beginning with pictograms in 3000 BC.
Ultimately it was completely replaced
by alphabetic writing in the general sense
in the course of the Roman era.
There are no cuneiform
writing systems in use today.
While the development
of Phoenician alphabet
is often attributed to,
of the phonetic alphabet is also
often attributed to the Phoenicians,
they didn't actually
invent it or create it.
Rather, they imported it
piecemeal from Egypt and Crete
and took it to every city
on the Mediterranean.
By the time of Homer, the
Greeks were taking over
the Phoenician or Aramaic
alphabetic writing,
and were calling it by the Semitic names
of the first two letter, alpha and beta.
The Latin alphabet was established
by the Seventh Century BC.
Before the invention of the printing press
in Europe around 1455, all books were
handwritten and usually highly decorated.
Until about the 12th Century,
the most elaborate and
beautiful illuminations
were devoted to religious works,
and most manuscripts were
produced in monasteries.
During the Middle Ages, the Latin alphabet
was used extensively
for writing in Europe.
With the age of colonialism
and Christian evangelism,
the Latin script spread
widely, well beyond Europe.
I'd now like to change the focus
to the history of English writing,
and explain how English writing ended up
with such a cockeyed spelling system
which leads in many cases to dyslexia.
The English language
itself is a compilation
of several different languages,
mostly Anglo-Saxon, French, and Latin,
because England just kept getting invaded
by people who spoke different languages.
The only thing we have in English
up until about 1400 are called patois.
They're a clumsy peasant language
without any standardized writing system.
There wasn't even a vocabulary
to carry on business in English.
It was all done in French or Latin.
However, when King Henry V took the throne
of England in 1412, he had
plans to invade France,
so speaking French wasn't gonna work.
He realized that if he wanted to get
support from the common people,
they would have to change the language
of Parliament and business
from French to English.
At this time the only people who could
write at all in England were just
a handful of men called chancery scribes,
who wrote by hand and
almost exclusively in Latin.
Latin has a transparent,
one-to-one correspondence
between the number of discreet
sounds, called phonemes,
in spoken Latin, and how they're mapped
by the letters in the alphabet.
As such, learning to read
Latin's a piece of cake.
All you have to do is
learn the single letter
that goes with each phoneme in Latin,
and then just pronounce them
in order to produce words.
King Henry V directed his chancery scribes
to create a written version of English
so that he could communicate
more broadly with his subjects.
However, there was
little or no instruction
as to how they were supposed to do this.
The problem they faced was that
the written Latin alphabet
was designed to represent
one-on-one each of the 23
phonemes in spoken Latin.
It was never fit well for
English, which has 44 phonemes.
For example, Latin didn't
have a SH, TH, or CH sound,
so with only 23 Latin letters,
there was no letter to represent these
and many of the other 44 English phonemes.
Faced with this problem,
the chancery scribes
just apparently made up
multiletter combinations
to represent these single phonemes.
So, for example, on this slide,
you could see that the letter string T-H-E
pronounced phonetically should be te-hu-e.
And S-H-E, sa-hu-e.
So as many children are
told, just say those
and blend them together
quickly, and what do you get?
Sa-hu-e.
In case you ever wondered how we
ended up with the nontransparent mapping
from spoken to written English
that leads so many children and people
learning English as a second language
to struggle to learn to read and spell,
it all began here in the 15th Century.
Nearly 600 years before Gutenberg,
Chinese monks were setting ink to paper
using a method known as block printing.
What really set Gutenberg's
technology apart
from the Chinese was the development
of a press that could mechanize
the transfer of ink from
movable type to paper.
For the first time in history
books could be mass-produced.
Gutenberg's first major work, in 1454,
was the 42-line Gutenberg
Bible, printed in Latin.
With the invention of the printing press,
printing soon became the first
means of mass communication.
Really, the first social media.
It put more knowledge in
the hands of more people,
faster and more cheaply, than ever before.
As a result, reading and writing,
which up until that time was really
something done by a very
very small number of people,
spread widely and rapidly.
Caxton brought the first printing press
from Bruges to London in 1476,
for the Canterbury Tales.
With the advent of the printing press,
the complex and often cockeyed
spelling patterns for English
that remain to this day were solidified,
giving rise to generation after generation
of children and adults
who struggled to learn
to read and write,
particularly in English.
Let me acknowledge here that I'm
indebted to a wonderful website
which I highly recommend to you
called Children of the Code dot org.
The website's creator, David Bolton,
gained much of the
information by interviewing
scientists and anthropologists
for many years,
and I've synthesized a
lot of that for this talk.
I highly recommend that
you explore this website
for additional information on this
topic of reading and writing,
the history of reading and
writing, and especially dyslexia.
I quote from David Bolton,
"There weren't any cognitive scientists
"or neuroscientists or psychologists
"or even child development
experts involved
"in creating the English writing system.
"There wasn't any concern for hundreds
"of millions of children
who would struggle
"since this code was
created in the 15th Century.
"There were just a small
number of chancery scribes
"doing their very best to shove
"a technology created for Latin
"into a language it was
never designed for."
Those who eventually do manage
to overcome the confusion
and learn how to break the code
to become phonologically aware
are able to use the areas of the brain
that reading has recycled
from speech and language,
these areas here.
Those who cannot break
this code become dyslexic.
According to the United
States Department of Education
in 2017, more than 60 percent of U.S.
K-12 schoolchildren are
reading below proficiency,
and more than 70 percent writing below
the level of proficiency
for that grade level.
Let these stunning numbers sink in.
Reading is a skill that matters
most to success in school,
and children who fall behind in reading
are in great academic danger.
But it's not just the
lack of reading skills
that most endanger these children.
It's the collateral damage.
It's their mind shame
that fates their future,
as seen on this video clip being shown
with permission of Children of the Code.
- My teacher asked me to come
to the front of the class and read a book,
and everybody was just staring at me
and I got real nervous
'cause I didn't wanna mess up or anything.
And then when I started reading,
I started messing up, and
I should couldn't help it
and everybody started
laughing at me and stuff.
- The teacher would ask
me to read something,
and I would read it and
I would get a wrong word
or I would go too slow and
they would make fun of me.
- I kept messing up on the words
and people kept laughing at me.
- They said that you
don't know how to read,
bet you won't be able to know
how to read when you grow up.
- They always laugh at me if
I get too stuck with words.
It makes my heart drop,
'cause it seems like they
not my friend no more.
- The collateral damage
caused by literacy problems
in the United States alone is immense.
75 percent to 80 percent of students
identified as learning disabled
have their basic deficits
in language and reading.
Academic success, as defined
by high school graduation,
can be predicted by knowing
someone's reading skill
at the end of third grade.
56 percent of students
with learning disabilities
will drop out of school and be arrested.
60 percent of adolescents in treatment
for substance abuse have
learning disabilities.
50 percent of females
with learning disabilities
will be mothers, many
of them single mothers,
within three to five years
of leaving high school.
Learning disabilities and substance abuse
are the number one reason
for keeping welfare recipients
from becoming and remaining employed.
Now I'm gonna turn to discussing
how modern technologies are impacting
reading and writing today.
Least we forget, the human brain
is an exquisitely adaptable machine.
Even though written language did not
evolve like spoken language did
over tens of millions of years ago,
since the invention of
writing and reading,
the remarkable neuroplasticity
of the human brain
has supported the rapid formation
of a highly elaborate
literacy brain circuit.
Literacy is a unique
epigenetic achievement
that changes what we perceive,
how we think, and how we feel.
That is, who we are.
I think it's fair to say
that reading and writing,
perhaps more than any other technology,
have had the greatest impact
on the advancement of Homo
sapiens brain and mind.
As we gain proficiency
in reading and writing,
the continual use of our
literacy brain circuit
feeds back, elaborates,
and strengthens itself.
But just as this brain circuit
developed very rapidly
in evolutionary terms,
or perhaps because it was so rapid,
this circuit is also
more vulnerable to change
if not continuously reinforced
by experience and use.
Only if we continuously
work to develop and use
the elaborated analytical, inferential,
and empathetic skills that have been
developed by literacy
will the neural networks
underlying these skills continue
to sustain our capacity to be attentive,
thoughtful, critical thinkers,
rather than passive consumers
of facts, real or fake.
Despite alphabetic writing not
changing much since the invention
of the printing press in the 15th Century,
modern technologies, particularly
social media technologies,
are having a very rapid
and profound effect
on writing practices in the 21st Century.
Interestingly, many of
these new technologies
are making less use of
alphabetic writing systems
and more use, once again, of pictographs,
as can be seen here, comparing
the Egyptian hieroglyphics
of 3100 BC to a thank you
note I recently received
from my niece that says
"Dinner was awesome,
it was a gift, thanks."
And another example, a Chinese pictograph
for medical marijuana,
originally from 10,000 years ago,
and a clip art symbol for
medical marijuana from 2017.
Since the 15th Century,
despite many changes
in spoken English, from Old
English to Middle English
to Early Modern and Late Modern English,
like here it says then she went
to speak the whatever English tongue,
written English has
used the same 26 letters
to represent the 44 sounds
of English, until now.
The bottom line reads
"Then she went to speak this
digital age English tongue."
Neuroscientists like me,
who specialize in reading,
are frequently asked these days,
how might these rapid
technological changes
in reading and writing
affect the human mind?
My colleague Dr. Maryanne Wolf focuses
on exactly this question in
her new book Reader, Come Home.
I'd like to close with
some of the profound
insights from this timely book.
As we move from a literary
and word-based culture
into a far faster paced
digital and screen-based one,
we face an existential dilemma
in this new millennium.
There are many things that would be lost
if we slowly lose the cognitive patience
to immerse ourselves in the worlds
that are created by books, and the lives,
feelings, thoughts, and insights
of the characters who inhabit them.
In a culture that increasingly rewards
immediacy, ease, and efficiency,
the demanding time and effort involved
in what Dr. Wolf refers to as deep reading
make it an increasingly embattled entity.
In closing I ask each of you
to consider this question.
Will the very plasticity
of the literate brain
as it begins to reflect
the characteristics
of digital media that we and our children
are increasingly immersing ourselves in
precipitate the atrophy of our
most essential thought processes,
sustained attention, critical analysis,
empathy, and reflection, and indeed wisdom
to the detriment of democratic societies
that critically depend on these,
the most essential characteristics
of the enlightened literate individual?
Thank you.